wieso läuft vorneweg bleibt stehen zum
glück gab es eine time stopper und
kennen die biobank freunde barcelos
herzlich willkommen hier zu einer neuen
was war das eigentlich eine behinderte
begrüßung willkommen ehe zu einer
weiteren folge der mannschaft commands
unter dem video
vorgestern wo ich eure snap chat sachen
mir angeschaut habe was ich übrigens
wärmstens empfehlen kann mal anzuschauen
da waren viele kommentare darunter ich
weiß nicht wieso gerade da aber da
meinten sehr viele leute machen wir
öfter die minecraft command sie ihr
gefällt euch weil die kuh bearbeitet ist
und weil ich euch gute sachen
vorstellungen blauen bleib ich möchte
aber dabei bleiben dass ich euch am
dienstag immer einen umfangreichen
command vorstelle wie ein der
beispielsweise letztes mal sechs oder
sieben bomben hinzufügt einfach und
heute stelle ich euch dann drei etwas
kleinere command obwohl die alle auch
schon wieder richtig geilen also ich
möchte bei der dauer bleiben das 4,1 in
der woche kommen ich hoffe dass es für
euch in ordnung dann würde ich auch
sagen hab ich wieder drei sehr coole
commands auf lager ihr wahrscheinlich
schon im titel gesehen heute ist etwas
cooles mit dabei und wir fangen einfach
direkt an mit dem ersten command ich
hatte halt in den letzten fünf bis zehn
folgen immer nur so richtig umfangreiche
guck mal die dann sowas hinzufügen und
sowas und plant erste command solltet
immer recht simpel sein und deswegen
bitte ich euch einfach wenn irgendwelche
simplen command kennt sowas wie wetter
umstellen oder irgendwelche zusatzeffekt
also dass hier wird jetzt kein kommando
ich das wetter um stelle passiert jetzt
auch sofort aber dann bitte einfach in
die kommentare schreiben dann würde ich
mich sehr darüber freuen dann würde ich
sagen macht voran mit dem ersten command
und zwar / wetter wenn ich dass einige
bekommt erstmal nix und dann seht ihr
mich diesen effekt weil normalerweise
wenn man das wetter umstellen will mach
ich zumindest immer einfach top down
voll weil wenn ich das wetter umstellen
will dann entweder von sonne aufregen
oder von regen auf sonne von regen auf
sonne ist eigentlich öfter der fall aber
wenn man webber eingibt und dann
beispielsweise rain thunder oder klier
und ich gebe es beispielsweise mit under
ein
dann kann man zwar gewitter jetzt machen
allerdings kann man dahinter noch die
dauer in sekunden schreiben das heißt
wenn ich hinter schreibe zehn sekunden
dann fängt es jetzt an zu regnen sodass
sehen wir jetzt dass im chait so ein
bisschen ausgestellt doch da sehen ist
jetzt da oben ist also
und wir hören auch donna und so weiter
das sieht ja mit dem bruderstaat trader
immer richtig geil aus und so und jetzt
seht ihr aber schon was passiert mit dem
himmel wie dabei ist alles wieder cool
und blau und der nebel verschwindet auch
gleich wieder und hier ist jetzt
eigentlich gerade vorhin war ja auch
alles noch so so glitschig mäßig das
verschwindet auch gleich wieder weil der
regen bzw der fahnder ist jetzt vorbei
nach diesen zehn sekunden das gleiche
kann ich auch machen wenn ich
beispielsweise man einfach cool down
voll ein gebe da kann man das vielleicht
besser zeigen seht ihr schon regt er
dass die ganze zeit wenn ich jetzt aber
weder klier fünf sekunden ein gebe es
schon wechsel zu schönem wetter jetzt
wird das wetter wieder kurz besser
gelegen hier kommen keine wassertropfen
hin
ich drücke nix und jetzt fängt wieder an
zu regnen damit kann man hier ganz coole
sachen machen also ich denke einige
wussten ist schon viele allerdings
wirklich noch nicht weil ich kannte man
nur das mit top down voll und halb mit
wetter aber nicht dass man eltern
sekunden anzahl schreiben kann
damit kann man echt gute sachen machen
wie beispielsweise halo es winken
mamazone da macht man sondern fängt
wieder an zu regnen könnte man bestimmt
mitspieler crew mit trollen sag ich mal
mehr oder weniger allerdings ist das
auch schon command nummer 1 also wie
gesagt komm mal erhielt soll immer so
ein bisschen simpel sein um reinzukommen
und jetzt machen wir weiter mit dem
zweiten command der schon wieder viel zu
krass ist übrigens müsste wissen dass
gerade hier arminia spielt gegen
wolfsburg gegen leider schon einzeln
hinten
ich bin nicht auf obwohl es ihn heute
mittwoch wegen den video days da bin ich
ja heute und morgen auch wieder wenn ihr
die folge seht und ich schnell grad die
minecraft mainz über meinen
lieblingsverein also dass das muss man
was heißen aber na ja wir machen weiter
mit dem zweiten command und zwar nicht
in dem game mode ich gebe mir nämlich
gfp command unterstrich block und dann
hole ich mir auch noch eben schnell
einen schalter und zwar ist der zweite
command sehr sehr umfangreiche zweite
command wurde mir nämlich zugesendet von
ebay monkey beziehungsweise habe ich ihn
bei ebay monkey gesehen und zwar gebe
ich dir einfach mal ein es ruckelt
wieder ganz kurz ich drücke auf den
schalter und wir sehen schon jetzt
wieder was nämlich eine kleine maschine
das seht ihr jetzt auch sofort wieder
und zwar ist es die slime snipers
maschine bzw
das sei etwas mini game und man kann
quasi mit diesem einem command in der
beschreibung findet eine komplette mini
game
dingsbums erschaffen hier sehen wir auch
noch mal alles davon eingeblendet die
kann man drauf klicken und an den
channel von dem anzuschauen hier ist der
clean up button hiermit starten wie das
spiel und die lieben wir die maschine
wie kriegen wir auf start game dann
sehen wir hier schon einen kleinen wenn
wir den töten geht es los und ihr seht
schon in der beschreibung hier habe ich
ein paar sachen und den töte ich jetzt
beispielsweise mal einfach und jetzt
habe ich mich dieses lärms nabu und
jetzt kommen wir nämlich seine front
geschossen aus dem himmel und ich musste
jetzt alle hier irgendwie töten ich bin
natürlich wieder der spezialist hier im
töten und muss jetzt quasi einfach ja
wie schon mehrmals gesagt habe ich
weniger konzentrieren das ist einer mit
der hauptgründe wieso ich kann mein kopf
mache ich muss jetzt diese ganzes leid
tut und geht rechts am rand kontrast
dass lime skills ich töte grad irgendwie
gar keinen 36 jetzt haben wir
beispielsweise 78 wenn ich jetzt mal
beispielsweise ihnen noch abschießen
steht rechts am rand jetzt neun dann
schieße ich hier das war die kuh das tut
mir leid
so zählen wir sehen auch schon dieser
bogen hat unzerstörbarkeit und
haltbarkeit und stärke level 99 und
endlichkeit des seins den geht nicht
kaputt und es ist unendlich mal viel
viel krasser als alles andere
und hier kommen halt immer mehr slams
runter und wer letztlich am ende die
meisten spams getötet habt am ende der
steil
der hat das ganze gewonnen also ich kann
das gegen mitspieler spielen auf dem
server ich kann einfach diesen command
eingeben und jeder wird dann hier drauf
gesetzt und muss dann die leute der
abschießen und na ja ich könnte jetzt
hier noch noch jahrelang weiter machen
hier die ganzen islam zu töten aber ja
das ist quasi so ein mini spiel
erschaffen von ebay monkey wenn ich hier
raus möchte macht man eben kurz hier
kaputt kann ich natürlich einfach
entweder das spiel halt beenden oder ich
gehe einfach kurz vor nach gebunden kann
ich die entweder autos entweder entweder
hierauf in china button drücken damit
tätigkeit zum paar seiner umgebung sind
die da vorne gerade sind oder ich klicke
hier einfach mal auf delete maschinen
wenn ich da hinkomme und lauf einfach
wächst ob ich sehe mich gemacht und zwar
sind jetzt schon immens viele slams das
ist command nummer 2 von ebay monkey das
ist die school hat das ist das la paz
minigame befindet video dazu seien
namen und den command und er ist dort
findet ihr natürlich selbstverständlich
alles in der beschreibung verlinkt ich
wollte jetzt eigentlich noch eben hier
die schmiede auseinandernehmen zu
schauen was bei für items drin sind
allerdings ist ja gar kein video
vorhanden allerdings sind hier wie sie
sagen sooft allerdings hier sind aber
meine ganzen paradies wieder am start
so behindert an roman nummer drei wurde
mir zugesendet von sap bzw habe ich die
seen by step ich sag immer noch
zugesendet weil ich das von der
minecraft facts dingsbums kenne übrigens
falls ihr euch fragt wieso die minecraft
wechseln etwa zeit nicht kommen dazu
habe ich gestern ein video gemacht das
finde ich auf meinem kanal einfach auf
meinem kanal schauen dass wir was ich
als lob laden habe da sind infos drin zu
die minecraft facts und warum die nicht
kommen und ich denke eigentlich dass
euch gefallen wird dass die zurzeit
nicht kommen weil er zurzeit etwas
cooles entsteht
aber das möchte nicht viel verraten also
einfach mal auf einem kanal chance
letzte video erklärt viel ausführlich an
zehn minuten warum dass die comcom
defekts nicht kommen ich hab mir wieder
einen befehl spock hier am start sei
maps i maps de mlp der hat diesen
command gemacht und zwar als ist die
times topmodel mit nur einem command ich
gebe nämlich diesem command eindrücke
auf pace klicke einfach mal drauf und
ihr seht schon ich kriege eine maschine
und diese maschine hat sogar eine uhr
dran
die uhr sollte eigentlich an diesem ding
dranhängen das ist ein bisschen crazy
gemacht ihr seht schon hier diese große
uhr steht quasi für genau das was dieser
ich sag schon immer mord weil diese
commands sind mittlerweile wie solche
mods aber wenn ich einfach mal auf
gästeteams körper darauf blicke seht
schon ich habe mit einem stop
das ist auch wundervoll dass ich dafür
gerade hier im village bin war da kann
ich euch das perfekt mal zeigen und zwar
gehe ich mal einfach kurz hier rein
damit die nicht raus können weil ich das
immer eben kurz so ich mach das mal eben
zu geben eventuell nochmal eine fackel
dass ihr hier auch ein bisschen was
sehen könnt und dann kann ich hier auch
ein theoretisch mal noch ein paar mehr
mops das licht ist voll wenig oder so
freuen ich habe jetzt mal anderen shader
reingepackt ich habe hier fackeln
gepackt und ich hab noch ein schwein und
ein schaf gesponnen und zwar seht ihr
schon wenn ich mit diesem timeslot
rechts ich mache oder so dann ist es
einfach ganz normal wie wenn ich
irgendein tool richtig machen oder so da
passiert nichts aber wenn ich jetzt
diesen times opfer beispielsweise
hinwerfe aktiviert er sich und hier
passiert nichts also wenn ich es
beispielsweise mal auf die wildschafe
drauf clique oder irgendwie was die sind
quasi die zeit gestoppt sage ich mal
nach einer bestimmten zeit habt ihr ja
gerade schon gesehen ist dann dieses
ding jetzt einfach kaputt gegangen da
müsste ich quasi einfach wieder nach
hinten hin laufen wieder sonne teils
locker hohen es mache ich jetzt auch mal
eben schnell da kann ich ja mal eben
schnell einfach hier draufklicken und
jetzt habe ich beispielsweise den
timeslot und wer für den neben das
hühnchen hier und ihr seht schon der
aktiviert sich und das hühnchen macht
nichts es bleibt einfach stehen ich kann
das wünschen jetzt hier boxen
das ist auch richtig cool für
irgendwelche wenn man sich so ein ding
holt sag ich mal sondern times
koppermann geht denn irgendeinen dungeon
rein oder so und dann so lange als
vielen opfern wird man einfach eben den
times opfer hin oder ist quasi alles
gestoppt also das bewegt dieser times
trapani kuhwiese leuchte formel weg
bleibt stehen fünf glück gab es einen
teilstopp freunde das ist quasi dass
dieser teil stalker macht hier sehen
jetzt schon hier beim das fing es kaputt
und die coole weiter vorneweg
ja das war auch schon der dritte command
der von sea map ist ihr findet seinen
kanal wo er das noch mal genauer erklärt
das video und den command natürlich und
in der beschreibung verlinkt und dann
würde ich sagen was ist jetzt auch schon
wieder für heute mit dem minecraft
command wenn es euch gefallen hat ist es
nur ein kleiner klick freund ein kleiner
daumen hoch wird man immer schon zeigen
die command sind cool bitte macht mit
der bärtige weiter weil es werden
vielmehr commands kreiert als es
wirklich in minecraft gibt also wirklich
es werden pro woche weiß nicht sehe ich
immer schon ich habe alle möglichen
kanäle abonniert kommen so 30 neue
command pro woche nicht einfach noch 434
vorwoche vor
aber dann wird halt immer so ein best-of
also das sind jetzt nicht die größten
kommentar hinzufügen aber so coole
commands allenfalls würde ich sagen
schaue ich jetzt mal weiter bielefeld
ich hoffe ich zeitgleich einfach wieder
den livestream ein und es steht 1 1 das
wäre einfach so einfach so hammer
na ja ich würde sagen wir sehen uns
entweder am morgen auf dem video des
falls ihr da seid um das video grad in
berlin schaut oder irgendwann in einem
anderen video wieder tschüss